here are this week's top movies in 1634  Amsterdam was captivated by a flower  tulip fever follows an unexpected  romance that threatens to tear a  marriage apart my son won't give me a  hug but that doesn't mean I love him any  less a single father helps his special  son grow up in a boy called pop don't be  afraid daddy so we have been penetrated  in unlocked a CIA agent doesn't know who  to trust as she seeks to stop a  potentially devastating biological  attack there's no time for guessing see  what's hot in theaters with this week's  fan tissa patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]